these all comforts James May
welcome
yeah very actually very seldom I can see
a walk and you have an I don't like it
no like you prefer not to
absolutely not those exhausting and very
old-fashioned Oh
medieval hey why do they call you
captain slow I mentioned that now and I
would jealousy I imagine is the main
leads are the two older presenters
yes well a lot of people call me captain
slow though the drivers of vans for
example often show captain slow with
some other words attached to it out of
windows um but inside I don't mind it's
quite a you know some people like a slow
man is it I mean you've been doing this
for it for ten years or so now uh and
cars really became your career uh was it
wasn't a sudden what is a master plan
was this something you you you well I'd
wanted I'd love to say yes but no to be
honest I never had you know there's that
expression that people like Australian
backpackers use a lot they say life is
what happens when you're busy making
plans for something else my life was
what happened when I wasn't making plans
for anything at all to be honest I was
sort of lying on the bed looking at the
ceiling wondering what to do when I grow
up and actually I still do that a bit so
this is just something that happened yes
it's it's you what you were a musician
what if well I did a music degree that's
a very long time ago now and I don't
think I ever believed I would be a
musician I don't think I was good enough
for one thing
so so what do you play the piano and
could you but you would impress me right
because I don't play anything I don't
know you might be a concert pianist on
yeah well I would uh I'm very rusty okay
but people are generous from their
describe you or are they are they can
they identify that you're rusty Oh
I think they can identify though but
playing the piano is one of those things
that I sort of slightly put on the hold
because I left University I did a I did
some quite mundane jobs some temporary
jobs and wandered around a bit wasting
my life away and then somebody gave me a
column to write on a car magazine
because I like cars and machines and
then I became a freelance writer so I
sort of starved to death for about three
or four years and then somebody said
have a go at the television so I did it
for a bit and then I stopped and I had
another little go and it didn't come
into anything and then suddenly there
was Top Gear and we didn't know Top Gear
would end at this big when we started
doing it it was just a car show as it
had been since the 1970s then all of a
sudden it blew up in our faces you know
it's like being a bad bomb maker I'm
talking about I'm talking about this I
mean so I can you ready the air I mean
it's been it's it's a huge success it's
it's a it's a it has a lot of copies
around the world - yes and and and you
obviously must have become a rich man
yeah
I'm reasonably well off yet because
because you have quite as I mentioned in
the opening you're quite many cars uh
even more more motorcycles yes what did
you say I said speaking I can say what I
won't because you know what I did say
that you have I think six cars uh yes I
thought I had five but I forgot that I
own one that's in a museum
where it should be eventually they're
just gonna put me in it and all he's
gonna throw oh yeah it's 64 a motorcycle
no foot no 42 or 42 was it yeah well one
of them says many anyway yeah and and
the plane yes
and what do you are you using this or is
it no no I spent most of my time with
the bikes mending them because they most
of them are quite old what kind of cars
do you prefer I mean well if you were to
choose do you like the big cars or
whether I like really small simple cars
I like the Fiat Panda I like smart cars
the Dacia Sandero arms I've talked about
that a lot it's got one fan and I do
like supercars because they are
ludicrous and they are unnecessary and
no nobody ever ran into a room in a
sweat saying God is there anybody here
who can drive a Ferrari because it's
just not a it's not a great
qualification it's meaning this but I
love them I love the I love the design
of them I love the outrage I like the
fact that they're sort of artworks and
if you if you drive one around this is
why I think you should keep them clean
and shiny if you drive them around it's
your sort of doing a service to people
you're giving them something nice to
look at rather than it no you are it's
the only reason I've got one I don't
know but if you if you have an art
gallery I do go to art galleries quite a
bit you you hang a picture on the wall a
lot of people have to go to Tate Modern
or whatever and they file past the
picture and they look at it but with the
car you can be walking around doing
whatever you do you're going to the
shops you're coming out of your office
and the car drives past and you go oh
look there's a Lamborghini that's nice
and really if you buy an expensive
painting if you've got a Rembrandt or
something like that you should hang it
outside your house
as people walk on they can see it this
is this is a brand new perspective yeah
and the truth is that the car is more
than coming from getting you from one
place to another it's it's also in a
philosophical way it's it's it's a
symbol of something isn't it yeah I
think I think cars are actually one of
the great love affairs of the 20th and
early 21st century it's been going on
for I mean the car has been around for a
hundred and thirty years but as a
practical proposition for the people in
common ownership it's only really been
around since the 1950s I suppose maybe
the late forties and we're still very
much besotted with the idea because I
still find when I get in a car and drive
along and I find this about the little
airplane I fly as well I there comes a
moment when I said anything is this
allowed I think am I supposed to be I
think yes no it's perfectly okay I'm
allowed to drive this car and it seems
like such a fantastic Liberty the fact
is it is a fantastic symbol of the human
spirit for going forth seeing things
looking at the countryside but not
stopping in it you know it's it's
empowered us in many impressive ways and
it is it is also to those who love it a
very important investment and all the
people will spend as little as much to
have as much car as possible because
they only need it they don't invest any
feelings in the purchase yes but even
that that's a bit like people who say
they're not interested in fashion and I
just wear jeans and a t-shirt but that
is a statement about fashion in itself
so if you own a car you can't divorce
yourself from neck saying something with
the car and when I was about 16 I was
madly in love with a girl called Liz and
I didn't know how to deal with actually
I wasn't even 16 I was about 15 and
eventually I went round to her house I'd
sort of repaired it or I think I might
have had a box of map matchmaker
chocolate sort of if anybody else here
is old enough to remember this rubbish
tasted the same as the plastic liner of
the box really
but that was the standing gift I had
that and I had some lines video and I
went round to her house where I'd never
been before and it was quite a modern
house and I went up to it and I turned
the corner and as I turned up the drive
I saw at the end of the drive a Volvo
two for four her dad has a dark gray
Volvo two for four and I knew it was
over
we're weirdly enough I saw her about a
year ago so we were 59 she's the same
age as me now she must be fit you know
she was 50 51 and she said it's such a
shame we never really got together when
we were young it's a good verdict see
dad's fault cause he had a Volvo so it's
a very effective contraceptive in the
late seventies the Volvo cooking thank
you so much for being with us here
tonight okay please welcome little Donna